thank you for the introduction good
morning everyone my name is Chaz Mason
augustin and more specifically time
series we have seen in the context of
monitoring with all the challenges that
it involves so I start by saying a few
words about baited up to give you some
context and then I'd go through the
world process of designing a focused
algorithm starting with identifying the
use cases where we're focusing on the
programs we've trained to self
identifying the challenges we have to
tackle looking at the literature and
what we can find there that could also
help us stop the program we also have a
look at the freely available software
that might already be doing what we want
to do we see how we design a great
burner Godin that forecast time series
and finally we explain how we prediction
eyes the algorithm and how we made the
most of the Python ecosystem to optimize
the algorithm and make it reliable and
fast to run in production so let's start
with a few words about data doc so dated
earth is a monitoring platform for
infrastructure and application it's size
based and so we collect with neck
metrics from application system
databases we can service kind of also
send custom metrics there may be
application metrics or business rate
related metrics we also collect
application traces and we collect logs
and you can see all of that in
dashboards such as this one and we
process trillions of data points per day
and we also have alerting pictures
including algorithmic editing features
that alert you when something is about
to get robbed or some interpretive wrong
in your infrastructure for example
anomaly and at higher detection and
predictive auditing which we need time
series forecasting for so first let's
focus on a few use cases for which we
need time series forecasting so I'll
take a concrete example here let's say I
want to move out the disk usage of one
of my server so is what the disk is it
looks like over time right now we're
about 83 percent of this being used and
it's clear that it's slightly increasing
and at some point if it stays with the
same trend is going to reach your 100%
special so am I getting sugar if my disk
gets full
and to get the defied before that
happens what I can do is set in
threshold at 90% for example and
whenever the metric which is that
special I get notified that I'm at 90%
it is being used the prime of that is
that when I get this notification unless
I look at the other graph at the series
itself I'm not sure if it needs
immediate action or if I actually wait
for one week before taking action for
example if we have this order metric
it's clear that this one requires our
interaction and the blue one and so if
we are bought to extend the trend in the
future to forecast answers in the future
we will be able to know when the metric
actually hits the 100% fair shot which
is what we are interested in and based
on that you can notify 24 hours in
advance or maybe one week in advance and
it's much more convenient than having to
set a special that's actually lower than
the threshold where it's programmatic
and we can apply this strategy for any
capacity matrix so maybe you are some
resources and you know that beyond a
given threshold you have to add more
resources by doing time cells for
calcium you can know when you have to do
that another example is this so let's
say we have a database here you can see
the lot of our time so let's say the
query rate you can see that there is a
weekly seasonality there are more
queries during weekdays so it's probably
user driven and I happened to have to
plant plants for maintenance on this
database so I plan a maintenance window
and I want to estimate in advance a much
load I will have on my database at the
time and time series forecasting can
help us with that so I can see here what
the load will be and I can associate
that probably I should postpone a bit
the maintenance window so that I am
doing the maintenance when the load is
lower and based on based on the forecast
it lost load story I can plan
accordingly
and make sure the maintenance we we
won't have what hit an issue
so since customers also sent
business metrics we might have to deal
with business related used
this customer might be sended business
data a financial metrics SS matrix so we
might want to ensure for example what
will the revenue of my company be in one
year from now or when we like to reach 1
million daily user on my platform and as
we started to look more into this use
case we started to meet some challenges
the first challenge that we met is that
because of those various sources because
the matrix can come can be utilization
metric can be latency error rate
business which weeks we have to deal
with lots of different patterns the
matrix can be seasonal there can be
noisy they can have spikes be piecewise
linear have anomalies that we might want
to avoid and for each and every of those
matrix we should be able to output a
forecast that is really well to the user
the second challenge that we met is that
we want the forecast to be adaptive and
reactive if there is a new new behavior
and the metric a new trend we want to be
able to detect this as soon as possible
so that we can alert as soon as possible
so here's a concrete example we again
have a disk is each metric we can see
that the disk wasn't used for so them
some time but then maybe we deployed an
application or we we started something
the dis started to get used and it was
filling up and it's clear that now if we
wait we probably going to be at capacity
and we we've know that for while
actually because the the slope is
consistent it's been consistent for a
while so we should be able on this
particular example to alert as soon as
we see this consistent consistent trend
in the series another example is this so
again a disk usage metric so we got
notified that we were going to reach the
capacity of the disk we took action with
the right advice or logs whatever was
filling the disk and now we have this
new level and we want the forecast an
algorithm to see that we have a new
level so that it doesn't notify us
saying that we're going to reach the
capacity of the days thats not the case
anymore and also we want the transition
during the level shift to be not to be
erratic
because otherwise we might have false
positives and that's not great
that's a mi
next point the focus should be robust it
should be robust - spikes - to noise
what we want here is to avoid false
positives and reduce Alan fatigue
because if you get too many false
positive well you're not going to pay
attention to true positives anymore and
it's going to be from a programmatic
here we have a metric which is the query
rate of the database we can see that
it's steady over time but then we have a
drop maybe soften up and then spiked so
probably if we process a backlog of
queries and then it went back to normal
and we like to focus on algorithm to say
okay this part is just nano money and it
shouldn't take this into account in the
forecast it should say that we are going
to have a steady wear rate in the future
another example is this so again a disk
is a metric so we this one is piecewise
constant but we see transitions and we
are currently in a transition and what
we don't want to see is this basically
over $13 the latest points and having
like this this forecast that would
trigger notifies for nothing could wake
you up in the middle of the night if you
get page for that and by the time you
grab your laptop to see what's happening
well it's clear that you got woken up
from nothing so we want to avoid this
and this example also shows that we
can't cannot solve the reaction F
reactiveness program by just taking a
shorter window because if you do that
you won't be able to take into account
the high level behavior of the metric
and I not challenge that we need the
focus to be fast to run for two reasons
the first one is that so the customer is
able to query time series by specifying
the metric the aggregation type then
they can add metrics together that can
smooth the series and on top of that
they should be able to forecast the
series and they should get the result of
the forecast
very fast so that the user experience is
great and the second reason for that is
let's say I have tens of thousands of
servers and I want to monitor the disk
usage on all of the servers this will be
tens of thousands of series to forecast
and I might want to do that on a regular
basis so that I know as soon as
change in behavior happens even if the
forecast takes a few seconds for each
series it's going to take a huge amount
of time I need a lot of resources and
it's going to be financially expensive
so I need the focus to be
computationally inexpensive to write so
with with all those challenges in mind
which we started to have a look at the
literature and what we can find there
and well there's a lot of things in the
rich literature about
timeseriesforecasting so for example one
classical method is the family of
autoregressive models proper ARIMA or
Saaremaa which stands for seasonal
autoregressive integrated moving average
so autoregressive means that the current
value of the series depends linearly on
the previous values of the series moving
average means that you're so other
stochastic terms term and the current
value depends generally on the previous
and current value of that stochastic
term that's what made makes the average
move integrated means that roughly
speaking you have to take the different
series to make it stationary and
seasonally it means that you take a set
of parameters of the area model so that
you model season seasonality
then we have exponential smoothing you
can't do it once single exponential
smoothing basically take the
exponentially weighted moving average of
your series if you do it on the
different series as well you're doing
double exponential smoothing and then
you can add a multiplicative term this
is xxx when I'm transporting and if you
take the smooth values and use them to
extend the series in the future you can
do a focus of your series and you can
imagine all kinds of variants of those
models then we have Kalman filters is
between here inherent to Kalman filters
to predict and mark on more
sophisticated models such as the
physical there and so on and there are
so libraries that are freely available
so if there is something that is already
implementing that and that is solving
our use case maybe we should cost
consider it instead of searching from
scratch so we had a look for example at
profits which is a library that is
available in Python and R that was open
sourced by Facebook data science team
last year it works with an additive
regression model with four components
first one is a piecewise linear our
logistic growth curve trend then we have
to seasonal components and we have a
user probably provided list of holidays
so this is great if for user-driven
matrix where the the the pattern on the
business day might differ from the
pattern on the holiday and we tried this
on some examples so here's a metric we
say daily seasonal item so before the
the now bar that we know about this is
the history of the series the actual
values and after we can see the forecast
with uncertainty bounds
so here the the seasonality is well
modeled then we try it with weekly
seasonal metric again the decision or ET
is where modeled but why they are some
inaccuracies during the weekend but we
could probably tune the algorithm it's
actually feasible with this profit so
that we don't get those those issues
during the weekend and then we tried on
all the series that don't have seasonal
pattern and this is what we get
and here the focus trap is not
consistent with any of the part of the
past and we don't really want to see to
see that here we'd prefer to see maybe
this the the latest behavior of the
series is is to be extended in the
future or maybe the latest behavior of
the metric is an anomaly and we still
want to focus on zero but something in
between it's not really what we want to
see and in the case of another ship this
is what really what we see and again I
don't want to serve those cases by just
taking a shorter window because this we
create other issues I might have among I
might not have enough points to make an
accurate forecast and my heavy shoes
during the transition when we have a
slope change our lever shift so I still
need to take into account the world's
the world series the world behavior and
my point is that models and models and
algorithm are designed with specific use
cases in mind and if you go beyond those
use cases well you have this kind of
behavior you have wrong forecasts
because well the model is not meant to
be used with this kind of series
but all of this was until machine on in
right so machine on in walks with lots
of domains so we should probably try
this waste time sales forecasting and we
did it so there's a lot of walks of work
going on with machine on in on time
series forecasting on literally hundreds
of publications there are lots of tools
pretty much or the machine learning
model are covered and I've been trying
for time series forecasting
material a perceptron so you have a
neural network with a single hidden
layer the output is the value that
you're trying to predict and the input
is the sequence of the ten last points
of course you train your model using the
historical values of the series K
nearest neighbor regression so here
again you take the ten last points you
look into the past for the decay
sequences of K closest sequences of ten
points you take the points after what
you take the average and that gives you
the broadcast then recurrent neural
networks and more specifically long
short-term memory based networks and
common applications are predicting the
prices of financial assets demand
forecasting has forecasting so we try
this in practice more specifically we
tried LSD on Bayes networks and we have
met a couple of issues it didn't go that
well so the first thing is that you need
to tune the algorithm a lot and you tune
them for a specific pattern and then you
go to another pattern and the forecast
is not yet great so it's hard to
generalize and the second issue is that
it takes time to train machine learning
models and in a production setting it's
might cause issues so if I summarize
some of the drawbacks of machine
learning methods so usually those models
work by points that they predict one
point the point is added to the input
and then they pretty the next one and so
on so it's not always great to more that
high-level trends or behavior also
related to the first point it's great
for short-term forecasting but for a
long-term forecasting it doesn't always
go that well
as I said a lot of Chinese needed it's
hard to generalize to various patterns
there is a severe eater focus in the
literature on and solidity estimation
one common method is to since most
machine learning models are not
deterministic you can run them several
times for the same point this will give
you multiple values of the point and
what you can do is based on how spread
out the points are estimator and
certainty but that's that's empirical
and there is not much story behind that
and finally there are computationally
expensive
so here are two quotations from recent
publications this one is from last
month's in this paper the author's
compare machine learning methods with
statistical ones and what they say is
basically that machine learning method
they're from war stance a statistical
ones and they also say that among the
the ones the machine learning method I
didn't bench box half of them they're
from worse than random work and but
their system what we known on previous
model for example in this other method
do first start by saying that Alice TM
based networks are great for short-term
forecasting but currently dot that bet
for long term forecasting and they
propose methods in the in depth in the
paper to improve the long-term
forecasting so at this point it was
clear that we couldn't apply any of
those algorithms or models as they are
so but there were still elements that we
can use in the literature to help us
focus some time series and what we did
is that we designed an algorithm that
first checks for seasonal patterns in
the history we can do that basically by
computing Auto correlations and based on
that it will apply to models the in the
seasonal case if the metric exhibit
seasonal pattern we make a prediction
based on Saaremaa
which is the demo that I talked about
earlier we were robust defied the model
by using millions across passes and the
idea here is that you don't want a
single animal in your matrix let's say
you had knowledge of something wrong
happening in your infrastructure a week
ago that completely changes the level of
the metrics you don't want this thing
to affect your forecast and so by taking
the medians you're getting rid of those
outliers so the disk under with weekly
daily analysis analysis and also we
require only specific windows of
historical data here again the idea is
that that by only querying for what is
necessary we were in the data store we'd
be faster and here is what it looks like
in practice so witnesses on the pattern
this is what we get and on the daily
seasonal metric we this is what we what
we get
however this doesn't work well this
method doesn't work well with non
seasonal cases when we have matrix that
is like that for example so in this case
we had to actually consider another
method and if if we if we focus on the
what we are trying to so what we want to
know here is when we are going to reach
that 100 percent threshold and well if
we dual in our forecast this that's
based on the best friend this will
actually be enough for us to solve our
use case and if you want to duel in our
forecast you just need an intercept and
a swap and for to get them you can
basically run a linear regression over
the past few hours for example and
extend this in the future so we can do
that and this is what we get
but again as previously which capture we
we deleted the files or the logs and now
we are this slowly and if if we still
apply the same method here we have to
take a window that is short enough so
that we don't we don't take into account
the global shift in the intro in that
window and this will be a very short
window that might create noise in the
slope in the forecast slop but with what
we'd like to do here is to be able to
exploit the fact that the slope is
steady before the lava shift shift and
if we can use this slop for the focus we
should be able to other a better
forecast so a way to do that is by
detecting side windows in industry over
which the series's consistent behavior
when I say consistent is basically
linear behavior so here you can see
three such sub windows
and if a sub window if the the behavior
of the metric over sub window is
consistent is mean are you can basically
learn run a linear regression and
compute the mean squared error which
tells you how good the fit is you could
just another indicator but the mean
squared error solves our case here
and on those two sub windows so a and B
be includes the level shift and we can
clearly see that the mean squared error
is much higher than for a so that's why
we should favor the window a over the
window be here but there are cases where
you can find several sub windows in the
past where the the behavior of the
series is consistent but the the
features of the does linear regressions
the slopes and the intercept are
different so you need to choose among
them which one is the the more relevant
and to do that we introduced two other
criteria for example if you consider a
and C here C is further away in the past
so we should favor a over C and D which
is the sub window during the deliver
shift is shorter than a so we favor a /
/ T here and so we have three criteria
goodness-of-fit
time in the past and with sub-window
lens we we turn them into weights and
then we basically take the way comedians
of all the shrubs and all the intercepts
and we use the weighted median as the
forecast slope and the focus intercept
and this is what we get so here we are
going to use this slope before the
loader shift to get our forecast and
most importantly during the transition
there is no erratic forecast so there is
no like your forecast that goes higher
or those we are things we can see that
it stays at a high low there for a bit
of time I'd after deliver shift because
at that point it might still be just an
anomaly and then the metric is going
back to the normal behavior and after we
showed that this is actually the the new
behavior of the metric then the forecast
changes we can also apply that to a
slope change and again we see that for
some time we're not sure whether this is
an anomaly or this is the new
a view of the matrix so we still focus
on zero and then we forecast Daniel can
you stop can apply apply that to a
metric with an anomaly and here the
focus Tina algorithm basically ignores
the G animal and finally on the metric
is a seasonal pattern so here we don't
apply the the non seasonal case we
applied the seasonal case which is
signed by base and we get a forecast is
stable enough so we we now have our
algorithm but there is something I
didn't talk about which is how many
which set of sub-windows were
considering in the non seasonal case and
it's clear that there is a trade-off
here between speed and accuracy if I
consider a lot of sub-windows I will
probably have an accurate behavior and
an accurate forecast
but it will politics takes time to to to
run so I need to know how many windows I
can consider and how many linear
revisions I can run in my garden and for
that I need to estimate how much time it
takes to run linear regressions it's in
Python and so we set up a very small
benchmark basically we generate two
arrays tune Empire is here with 300
elements in each of them X represents
the time stamp time steps and y
represents the values of the time series
and then we have this window balance
function which basically generates the
bounds of all the possible sub windows
within the array so we're taking the
worst case here where we actually use
all the sub windows that we could use if
we benchmark this on a few common
libraries so we can start with numpy it
takes 3.5 seconds if if we use non Pipal
if it takes five point eight seconds
then scifi 12 seconds start small F 15
seconds we could also use scikit-learn
which actually cause side panel in ivory
square which ends up pulling the same
latitude as temple in le square so we
would have a similar time for for this
and at this one it's clear that we we
won't be able to consider order of the
sub windows and run linear regressions
on
all the sub-windows because it's going
to take too much time but since we run
this query version we can actually do
something else we can run them
algebraically so with addition
multiplications so but what's important
here is that basically if you define spq
as being the sum of the X to the power P
Y to the power Q you can compute the
slope and intercept this way beta and
alpha beta be in the stock and a fur
being ingested here and so you can very
basically implement this in Python it's
just a few lines of code so you are the
s PQ beta and I fast those are the pure
transposition of the formulas of the
previous slide and if you bench burn
this this is what we get 1.5 seconds so
it's a bit better the previous best one
about 2.7 seconds I think but still not
that bread but if we start looking more
so roughly i what we are doing here so
we're looking over all the sub windows
and we for we have completing the linear
regression for each tab window
independently we call this function on
with I and J which are the bounds of the
sub window and if I and here so I have I
defined the SP q for each I and J but
what I could do is walk in with matrices
so basically having big matrices with
that contains all this SP q for each sub
window which we can also write this way
so from a mathematical point of view I'm
not changing anything here we're doing
exactly the same calculation but from an
implementation point of view here we
could use an empire ace and when we use
an empire race we can actually use the
Empire functions to generate those those
sums so we chain 3 and PI functions as
we do here in other s dict contains
matrices instead of single variables
beta and alpha our calculation on
matrices and as you know when you do
algebraic operations on the PI RS you're
doing then element wise and finally
reach an alpha and beta which are the
matrices of all the intercepts and the
slopes and when we run that we get this
5 plus 5
seven milliseconds so we are now running
tens of thousands of linear regressions
in Python with a few lines of cards in
five point seven minutes ago so it's
much faster than what we had previously
and the secret here is that's a secret
but it's just that we are making the
most of an empire basically so as you
know and then PI beyond the fact that it
has a lot of convenient functions it's
it's a library that was written for
performance a large part of a new pie's
written in c and by using the pi you're
doing a lot of a computation instead
instead of doing the computation python
so you avoid some overhead we also have
special locality the new PI RS are asked
starting contiguous blocks of memories
so when the CPU retrieves the data the
data in theory to run the algebraic
operation you have seen fewer cache
lines so it's it's again less time and
also because of the previous point you
can make the most of vector as
instructions so as as you know modern
CPU architectures have vectorized
instruction sets for example fvx and SSE
for Intel xop for MDM and what that does
is within the same number of number of
CPU cycles instead of walking on a
single variable you're going to walk on
vector of 13-point values and you're
doing the calculation on multiple 14
point values for eight or sixteen at the
same time so that's and that's something
we can do because the values are
continuous in memory so this method is
correct you can actually we actually
applied it in several several times in
algorithm to compute the mean squared
error you can do the same thing you can
compute them algebraically to compute
the weights but it doesn't always work
because if you have more complex
calculation to do you might not have the
new PI functions already implemented and
you might not be able to structure your
data in an empire but what you can do
well you're a lot of things that you can
do for example we used sector so we
compute the bounds the uncertainty
uncertainty bounds of our caste we had
to compute rolling quarters and because
the because were to deal with gaps and
non values we couldn't use
classic Olympic functions for that or
any other libraries so we have to
implement deposit ourselves we first did
it in Python and then we did it in sight
on so a second is a superset of the
Python language that lets you write C
like performance code mostly written
pattern but you're able to allocate
memory work with pointers so you have
access to lower level instructions and
it's actually compiled and so we did
that for already rolling context and
this is what we got so here you can see
the 99th percentile of the query
duration that includes retrieving the
data from a focus in the series and
post-processing the series so the the
full pipeline and we went from 1.2
seconds to about 1 seconds so it's still
a 15% increase just by rewriting the the
during contact computation in psiphon so
I like to conclude with a few key
takeaways so I'm not saying anything new
here but just some points I like to
highlight again we forgot to the to the
talk that they stock so that the first
thing is that each formation you can
what I mean here is that when we know
the the first one's doing time series
focusing but still we weren't able to
use anything in the literature or any
library as as they are we had to adapt
to change and the reason for that is
that because of the way how you use the
output of your forecast you might have
cost trends you might have challenges
that you have to tackle you might have
to work with if you little data actually
you might have a lot of data and you
might want to make the most of it of it
and so that's why you I mean I I say
it's prevents unique so the second point
is that machine learning can solve
everything so machine I'm not saying
machine learning is it's not bad I mean
it's it's there are some domains where
it's it's actually great for image I
mean we can
you know that it's doing a lot of things
but there is a like people want to tend
to want you to use machine learning for
everything and somehow it's
understandable because if you if you go
beyond the scientific aspect of it if
you think about like marketing it's
great for companies to use diploma in
artificial intelligence as a selling
argument it works customers get exactly
they want to know more about a product
that they try the features but at the
end of the of the day what counts is the
output of the algorithm and what what
the brand-new value that it brings and
so the way how you do that doesn't
really come at the end of the day so if
the if the output is not better
necessarily good idea to use machine on
it sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't work and also that there is
another point which is that it's hard
sometimes for scientists to accept that
that's not because you have a more
sophisticated models that you're going
to have better outputs sometimes a basic
program a basic model or algorithm can
work the third point is people are
simple so if we look in in the rest
Rachel's retrospect at what we did here
so we run mini regressions which is
rather basic everyone understands what
linear regressions is then we analyze
the situation then we realize that maybe
we should run on several windows and
then we had we realized that maybe we
should favor some some windows over
other ones so we defined criteria we
should use weights for that then we take
to the weight in million because we
wanted to get rid of the outliers and
now if I see a bad forecast with the
algorithm I know I know what I need to
do to fit the forecast I know what I
need to address the tune and if I worked
with Alice for example well I'm I'm not
sure I fully understand even how a
single SDM works I mean from a
theoretical point of view I might
understand that particularly inertia of
the intuition needed to work whistle STM
especially when you actually work with
and networker fallacy in themselves and
that's why I mean some sometimes it's
easier to have basic
that you can understand fully and that
you can easily tune and finally the last
point is that so it's great to to use
Python to define algorithm to design
them to try them very convenient you
have lots of powerful libraries and when
it comes to prediction izing the gr
greater where Python works as well you
can use all the Python ecosystem to
optimize the job rhythm to make it more
robust and you don't need to rewrite you
country any other languages or any other
technology so that's and my talk I'd
like to thank the PI that our team for
organizing the conference and inviting
me here so if you're interested in
working on challenging topics such as
the one I talked about we have lots of
open positions so feel free to reach out
and if you have any questions I believe
we have a few minutes but you can also
reach me by email
[Applause]
any questions
thank you for the talk very interesting
I'm curious on the application of the
Facebook prophet too it has the option
to because ultimately the use cases you
showed and how didn't perform well was
because it didn't detect the change for
and
where there was a change in slow it has
options for like change point detection
and obviously seasonality on and off in
all sorts of granular like time analytes
and frequencies
I'm curious as to whether you actually
tuned and played with the options and
especially changed for detection one
show that you hopefully you would have
gotten better results when that Facebook
profit to so profit was probably meant
to for business time series so yeah
business ratio time series financial
time series data and that's that's why
he cannot read it here with those
complete change of behavior it it's able
to deal with slope changes but not
really the ones we see here so those
those are the examples that I show are
pretty much the the the the forecast we
sell any any tuning and if you tuned
more you might be able to get better
results but yeah there are some some
things that I would like to avoid here
so the for example the fact that
sometimes you don't want to take a
shorter history window because you might
miss the aisle over PA view and that's
why even when you tune the model so you
might be able to have better focus for
some patterns but not necessary for for
all the patterns so that's why we ended
up writing our algorithm
hi thanks it was great talk but my
question is I so use a saaremaa for the
bottom in that example there and then it
was this the kind of simple linear model
for that the top one how do you decide
which model you're gonna use up front
like do you is that user deciding that
or is that automatically so we run in
variations on the on the time series so
that we know if the series a seasonal
patterns and then based on that we reuse
for the for the per year for the monitor
one or the other model but the user can
overwrite this so if they want to use
maybe during a model because they're
more interested in the longer-term trend
and they don't really care about the
this is no pattern they can do it when I
can also uses the season algorithm if
they want to actually focus on the
seasonal pattern and so the question for
the top graph um how do you build the
confidence interval around the linear so
what we so concretely what we do is that
we consider the smaller there were
linear regressions without the smaller
some windows and we used the arrows to
basically say how much noise how much
local noise we can get in the series and
based on that we compute the bands and
that's why you can see that at some
point the lower bounds is wider than the
upper bound because basically we have a
lot of drops and the algorithm is about
to say okay to see this and and to make
the thank you
hi thanks for the talk
can you please clarify how you selected
the sub-windows because you could have
an infinite combination of them so we're
actually considering all the possible
some windows over history so if I want
to predict to forecast over the next
week I'll use one week of data and with
that weaker data let's say out of 300
points I will consider all the possible
sub windows and then I give them weights
based on the three criteria talked about
but I keep all of them and some of them
we are very low weights if if the
behavior is not consistent on them some
other we have high weights and then I
use the weighted million over all those
slopes so there is no prediction of the
sub-windows I'm just taking all of them
because I can because it runs fast
enough and then I favor some of them
using the weights
thank you look I'm wondering if you have
any feedback from the quality of the
forecast because I imagine I mean
topcase here and let's say we find
anything I have an anomaly and so the
feedback would be the forecast is be
gonna be worse for every Friday evening
and you might choose like some kind of
so I check in about customer feedback or
rather feedback system that tells how
good yeah oh I'll suggest you know you
use that some kind of Lynnea weather
maybe so we we started to design some
current system or feedback system that
says how good the focusing is the prime
is that it's actually hard to come with
a scoring system that is good enough for
for specific use cases and for example
when we take the if you take the example
disk use a metric sometimes you want to
to forecast that is going higher but
most of the time the the customer
actually takes action and delete files
but you don't want to to to say that
it's a bad forecast if you if you don't
actually predict that it's going lower
so we started to design a storage system
with a way to get feedback but at the
end of the day we were tuning the score
system instead of tuning the algorithm
itself so yeah we were took a rather
pragmatic approach where we looked at
the forecast on a few programmatic
examples tens of them and we wanted
forecast to be good for all of them and
this then we saw that it generalized
well to two other series that's all the
type of questions please take other
questions offline thank you so much
you